hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga except
not really because here we're all pretty
open about our twisted love for hunter
hunter so today i would like to present
10 shocking facts about the series that
you may or may not know because this
series has a pretty crazy history with
some truly bizarre and astounding events
happening not only in hunter hunter
itself but also surrounding its
production
as well as some very bizarre occurrences
surrounding the production of this very
video such as you not being subscribed
to the new world review which is utter
madness because doing so would grant you
regular
hunt hunt content uploaded straight into
your youtube feed so click the button
join our association and let's talk
about some weird stuff starting with
shocking fact number 10 you do not
pronounce the x
in hunter hunter i must apologize for
starting off with what is a rather basic
fact but i know i just know there is
someone out there who desperately needs
to hear this you do not pronounce the x
and it is particularly astonishing to me
how many other significantly more
prominent youtubers continue to call
this series hunter x
hunter but with that said i guess it is
a slightly confusing name for western
audiences you see this
x is butterclever ruse and is in fact a
multiplication symbol and it's really
hard to describe the vague meaning
behind it but basically it's just here
to indicate an interaction between
two words as well as you know just look
kinda cool
because that's the thing that happens in
japan take you hakusho for example
it has ornamental stars in its title but
you would never call it you star you
star hakusho
or maybe you would in which case you're
strange and please bring this disturbing
behavior to a halt and if you did want
to be
super semantically stubborn then feel
free to call it hunter times hunter i
suppose but no more of this hunter x
hunter business alright good now with
that out of the way let's move to
shocking fact number nine the author of
the hunt hunt manga yoshihiro tagashi
is married to naoko takeuchi the mangaka
of a little-known series you may have
heard of called sailor moon
so this is what we would call an
industry power couple and this is quite
relevant because after the conclusion of
sailor moon takeuchi became heavily
involved in hunt hunter which togashi
was just commencing and originally
takuchi played the role of togashi's
manager handling all sorts of office
administration before apparently being
fired from that position by her future
husband and at this point
she would put her artistic abilities to
use by colouring hunt hunter a task in
which takuchi was quite successful at
and was able to mimic togashi's art by
using the mantra of making her work as
ugly as possible
which worked very well actually her time
with the series didn't last past the
first volume though and the whole
tagashi takuchi relationship
is is quite a tumultuous affair with
takeuchi even calling their wedding off
on one occasion which has also led to a
fun internet joke about her wanting to
put their wedding on hiatus in the same
way that togashi would go on to
frequently put hunter hunter on hiatus
however things do seem to have worked
out in the end and the two are still
together to this very day after more
than two decades of marriage
so that's nice but let's refocus on
hunter hunter with shocking fact number
eight
tagashi may have already spoiled the end
of hunter hunter or at least the fates
of certain characters
quite specifically karapika and the
phantom troupe this is a now infamous
interview that occurred in volume 0
which is notable for being a prequel
focusing on krapika's life in the kurt
clan
prior to the phantom troop massacre in
any case amongst a slew of questions
contained as bonus material for the
volume tagashi was fairly blatantly
asked what will end up happening to
karapika
and the phantom troupe to which tagashi
quite plainly replied
they will all die and unfortunately
there was no follow-up question to that
so
this is what we have to work with and
this has led to a bit of division of
opinion in the hunt onto fanbase with
many believing that togashi's words were
intended as a joke
something that could very well be true
but is difficult to judge from printed
media whilst the other school of thought
is just to accept tagashi was telling
the truth and that the ultimate fates of
these tragic characters is to be erased
from this world it's an idea that
current manga events do support but only
time will tell
although even then let's be real maybe
time will decide to keep this one a
mystery however what is less of a
mystery is shocking fact number seven
the protagonists in hunter hunter all
have
mildly relevant birthdays or at least a
nice little feature where assumedly
coincidentally each protagonist of the
series is born on the same number
day that corresponds with that numbered
month of the year so for example
aorio was born on the third of march
thus making his birthday the third of
the third moving to krapika he has the
same thing going on being born on the
4th of april being the 4th of the 4th
and 1 month further we land on gon whose
birthday
is the 5th of may the 5th of the 5th
although this carries a bit of extra
relevance because the 5th of may is
actually a national japanese holiday
known as children's day and many child
protagonists of the manga realm have
that date assigned as their birthday but
skipping ahead to killwa he was born on
the 7th of july or the 7th of the 7th
however the most interesting part about
all of this
is that hisoka also fits quite nicely
into this trend having been born on the
6th of june or the 6th
of the 6th which is a key piece of
evidence used by fans when claiming that
hisoka is indeed
the fifth protagonist of hunter hunter
really intriguing stuff there but for
something just plain bizarre here is
shocking fact number six aunt hunter
spawned not just one but two
live-action musical extravaganzas now
that fact in itself isn't necessarily
strange in fact most mainstream anime
and manga tend to have a slew of
musicals dedicated to them in japan at
some stage or another but the hunt
hunter musicals well
they're particularly weird especially if
you've never seen hisoka's dance which
you should absolutely
look up on the youtube but the first
production is named musical hunter
hunter and it takes place theoretically
between the events of york new city and
greed island which basically sees the
core group on a mission to recover four
missing performers who each have
starring roles in an upcoming theater
festival meanwhile the second one would
be hunter hunter the nightmare of
zeoljec
because they spell zoldik the way the
data books do but this is uh
it's a sort of retelling of the zoltik
family arc although i think reimagining
might be a better word and it is
interesting because both illumi and
hisoka play major roles despite not
having been in the actual arc and what i
will say is someone who has worked in
musical theater for
most of their professional life is that
these shows are very paired back
productions minimal set basic lighting
and these shows are almost exclusively
carried by the performers which is very
much in line with traditional japanese
theater so look into them if you're keen
but speaking of keen we have shocking
fact number five
miss universe japan fantasies lyorio
alright a bit of background here we
are talking about yukimi matsuo who was
crowned as miss universe japan in 2013 a
year which now seems shockingly
shockingly far in the past but in
addition to being an actress a model and
competing in beauty pageants she is also
a passionate manga artist and all-around
lover of anime
manga and games in fact during the
japanese national contest she stated
that her ambition was to spread her love
for manga around the world
and she also went on to reveal that her
ideal man would be one
layorio from hunter hunter which i think
is a much needed win for laero in this
whole hunt under saga and it does make
some degree of sense given that he is
one of the few
characters in the series who you can
objectively consider something of a good
person given that his life is dedicated
to philanthropy and all i guess it's all
just a bit of a shame that he happens to
be you know
fictional though and as such he will
never get to know that he was
hand-picked by a miss universe
contestant no well no time for dwelling
on that now because we have shocking
fact number four the character of dwoon
is based on yoshihiro tagashi himself
and that's not
a flattering basis so if you're a more
casual fan just a quick recap dwin is
one of the game masters of greed island
and he is most notable for having his
name forcibly changed by jing in order
to fit the initial base naming scheme of
the title but when gone aces the trivia
section and officially beats the game he
is taken to dwin's room which is
portrayed as your typical hikokumori
existence
filled with but three things a man a
game
and an ass ton of garbage and this is
very much based in reality as togashi
has been known to adopt this lifestyle
from time to time and a very famous
picture exists of him playing dragon
quest in a room that can be best
described as a stye
and look full disclosure i'm not the
cleanest to people but this is too much
even for me and this photo is one of the
famed pieces of evidences for the lazy
tagashi argument portraying him as an
addicted gamer with no drive to actually
finish hunter hunter and while it's more
complicated than that there is no
denying that togashi does get wildly
absorbed into whatever singular focus he
has at any given time and the
culmination
of this personality in hunt hunter just
so happens to exist in dwin so that's
fun but moving on we now have shocking
fact
number three gone's arms are cursed not
literally of course which i do need to
point out because none curses are a
thing but in almost every arc gone ends
up suffering a grave injury to one of
his arms during the hunter exam his left
arm was quite brutally broken by hanzo
in the finals
in heaven's arena his right arm was
broken by guido's spinning tops then in
york new city the rider once again fell
victim to arm wrestling with nobunaga
but still that was probably quite
preferable to greed island where part of
his left arm was blown off entirely by
genthru's little flower although i will
remind you that this is a tactic that
gone had planned to occur because that's
what sane people do and then of course
in the chimera antarctic his right arm
was well and truly severed by
nephipito's post-mortem nen in fact the
only time gone's arms ever really get a
break in the series
pun intended is during the zoldic family
arc or i guess the election are but even
then his arm was shown as a withered
husk
it's just one of those motifs of hunter
hunter potentially designed to highlight
god's sheer recklessness
because these injuries never occur
accidentally they always happen because
gone is stubborn and rash in his
decision making but then again in the
complete opposite direction we move to
shocking fact number two the chimera
antarc
took seven and a half years to complete
and this does blow my mind somewhat but
the very first chapter of the chimera
antarctic entitled the queen
was released in june 2003 whilst the
last chapter titled
final will would not be released until
october 2011.
and that is quite the long slog i wasn't
reading at the time
nor had i watched the 1999 anime but i
can't help but feel for all of you
long-suffering hunter hunter fans during
this period it really does put
complaining about the pacing of other
series into perspective but of course
pacing really isn't the issue here is it
it's more about the plague of hiatuses
that really emerged during this arc and
what i will say is that i do certainly
come closer to identifying with older
readers more and more because a rather
shocking sub fact here is that the
current arc being the succession war has
now been running for six and a half
years as its first chapter was published
in august of 2014
and look i don't really know what to say
because i suspect that if and when this
arc does finish
it's going to take much much much longer
than the chimera antenna
and that's mostly because of shocking
fact number one
with every day that passes we set a new
record for the longest hunter hunter
hiatus
yep that's right i'm afraid that we are
currently living in the darkest point of
hunt under publication because at the
time of this recording hunt hunt has
been absent in 89 issues of weekly
shonen jump making this by far the
longest wait between chapters we've had
and i mean there have been
similar hiatuses in the past one of
which lasted 80 issues
and another lasting 79 issues but 89 and
counting is a disturbing record to be so
consistently breaking as it currently
stands there has not been a new chapter
of hunt hunter since december 2018 so we
are rapidly approaching our first
instance of experiencing two full years
without a single installment and while
this is a record for all of the worst
reasons it's still a pretty interesting
fact and well worthy of our number one
place here today but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're game for
some more hunt hunter content then
please to go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunter hunter glory
delivered straight into your youtube
view but for now this has been the new
world review
and i'll see you next time